there was another monday night game last
night too though the bears season has
just fallen completely off the rails i
mean realistically they probably should
have parted ways with matt nagy earlier
on it's not the way that chicago has
done things was this more about chicago
falling off or the vikings who now
quietly get back to 500 are going to
have a huge sunday night game coming up
against the packers not this week but
the following weekend
i'm not worried about the minnesota
vikings right now but what i'm looking
at is the chicago bears and you heard
the announcers all night they just could
not believe how poorly coached this team
is you know they kept saying how tough
these guys are playing these guys are
playing tough they're doing everything
they can but penalties turnovers
mistakes undisciplined play well who is
that a reflection of that's a reflection
of their head coach and the play calling
was absolutely horrendous they got it
like i told you a couple weeks ago with
the bears when they played the green bay
packers they have to surround
justin fields with more talent all the
talent around them is just pretty good
it's not anything great no one explosive
just just basically average talent so if
they want to see him continue to
struggle
and think about the defense the defense
is getting older so as
matt maggie is screwing up the chicago
bears the defense is an aging defense
and they're just not the same robert
quinn is their best player right now
and real quick well there's count that's
right and there's countless examples of
young quarterbacks going into bad
coaching situations and it just ruins
their career right it just ruins it
before they even get started their
confidence is gone and my fear is that
that could happen to justin fields the
longer they keep matt and aggie as his
coach and that's what i don't want to
happen for justin fields there was a
couple plays last night where i just
thought fields was doing too much this
is one right here look how long he's
holding the football just throwing at
that running back's feet right there man
don't take that hit don't take that sack
fumble there's another one where he just
is holding the ball for three or four
seconds longer than he should he's just
handing to neil hunter a sack this is it
right here run backwards you can't do it
another sack so just no matter what
you're doing just try to get that ball
out of your hands even if you're just
throwing it away when he gets in trouble
is when he's holding it for five and six
seconds and in this league maybe at ohio
state you can in this league it just
never seems to produce a good result
so what you're what you're describing
right now is coaching that's basically
what you're describing or lack thereof
and that's what he needs he needs
somebody that he can bond with we talked
about this that he can bond with that he
could connect with he's not connecting
with matt nagy he's just not and it's
evident on the field the product that
they're putting out on the field
i know and then nagi's going nuts just
losing his cool on the sidelines and it
almost feels like it's just the final
punch right it's just his final
shot one final haymaker like a tired
boxer trying to throw that last big
right hand out there even though you
lost the fight and and that's just what
coach nagy has come to and i don't think
it's healthy for coach nagy i don't
think it's healthy for this locker room
i certainly don't think it's healthy for
justin fields and i understand that it's
not the way that the bears do business
to move on from their head coach in the
middle of the season but it may be time
for a new way of doing business in
chicago and that's what i really think
needs to happen
i agree with what you just said
[Laughter]
yeah exactly pace as well is gonna above
naggy probably a similar result do you
think the minnesota vikings wind up
making the playoffs now that they're
back to seven and seven few tough games
down the stretch like is this a team
that could go into lambo and beat aaron
rodgers in your opinion
they're very familiar with aaron rodgers
but going into lambeau field man we we
saw the atmosphere and we see when when
he's at home he's just special man aaron
rodgers is just special and we talk
about all the great quarterbacks and tom
being a leader in mvp man aaron rodgers
is that guy and you know it's just hard
to bet against him every time i bet
against aaron rodgers i've lost i
learned one thing don't bet against
aaron rodgers
i'm right there with you on that so
here's here's what the vikings have
coming down the home stretch now at
seven and seven you just saw they're
hanging on for that final playoff spot
they got to play the rams though they
got to go to lambeau like we just talked
about and then they get the bears again
i don't i don't think they get in if
they're eight and nine eight nine
records probably not going to be good
enough they probably have to go win at
lambo or figure out a way to beat the
rams but the rams are currently getting
hot again too
what about not well what about if they
lose to the packers but win against the
rams and the bears
that's the road most likely right yep oh
yeah
yeah it almost looks like they have to
win all three huh
they've just let so many games slip away
this year right like how many fourth
quarters this season for the vikings
where they've just lost a game that they
had in the bag or it felt like that they
were going to win and they just blew it
late and every single week we'd come on
this show and go those are the ones that
are going to cost them that's the game
it's going to cost them and now that you
get towards the back half of the
schedule all of those close losses have
caught up to him and really
you're probably looking at coach zimmer
coaching for his job these last three
games if they win two out of the three
maybe he keeps it if they just win one
out of the three you may be looking at a
couple of teams right there with an
entirely new regime coming in
well i'm looking i'm looking at if he
doesn't make the playoffs how do you
keep mike zimmer how do you keep him
he's an older coach i mean he's been
there for a long time they're not going
to the super bowl it's not like they're
they're fighting for nfc championships i
just think that you might have to look
at getting somebody a little younger
maybe a new fresh a little fresher and
somebody with a different perspective
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports